[Musique]
manifestations en cours à paris contre
le pass sanitaire le cortège et vers
l'assemblée nationale où le projet de
loi concernant l'extension du pass
sanitaire est examiné par les députés
le rebond épidémique poursuit sa hausse
à travers la france avec 21 mille
nouveaux cas de contamination commis 19
ans 24 heures que jean castex de son
côté réaffirme sa volonté de vacciner à
tout prix le premier ministre annonce
ouverture de 5 millions de rendez vous
on est quinze prochains jours
[Musique]
en tunisie la situation sanitaire
continue de se dégrader le pays fait
face à son pire pic de contamination de
la pandémie en tenaille d'acquérir l'une
des plus importantes fêtes musulmanes
les tunisiens n'ont pas le coeur à faire
la fête faute de moyens à tunis
l'inquiétude est palpable notamment
concernant la campagne de vaccination
totalement désorganisée
emmanuel macron ordonne une série
d'investigations à la suite du scandale
d'espionnage spe qu'asus que jean castex
est dit est très préoccupé par cette
affaire le chef de l'état ferait
potentiellement partie des personnalités
politiques espionné par le maroc bien ce
logiciel israélien son existence a été
révélée à lundi plus de cinquante mille
numéros ont été piratés à travers le
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france nous
sommes dans la quatrième vague annonce
de jean castex cet après midi chez nos
confrères de tf1 21 mille nouveaux cas
ces dernières 24 heures le variant delta
à continue sa progression à travers la
france une seule solution la vaccination
pour l'exécutif
le premier ministre a réaffirmé sa
volonté de vacciner un maximum de
français avant la rentrée objectif 50
millions de primo vacciner avant fin
dans les quinze jours qui viennent on va
ouvrir 5 millions de rendez vous dans
cette merde c'est pas seulement ouvrir
pour vous dire vous aura un rendez vous
le 20 août bien d'autres quels objectifs
on a eu bien compris vous mettez
l'accent sur la destination mais
l'objectif alors si frais cgj 40
millions de primo vacciner à la fin de
ce mois on est bientôt à rogner oui sauf
que c'était 40 millions fin août
oui on condamnera et 50 millions sans
doute payé est là pour vous dire cette
semaine on devrait sceller primo
vaccination c'est votre question on
devra en faire deux millions ce 21
juillet marque l'entrée en vigueur de la
première étape du pass sanitaire dès
aujourd'hui il faudra donc présentés
sont pas sous un test négatif de -2 48
heures pour pouvoir entrer dans de
nombreux lieux accueillant plus de 50
personnes
le projet de loi débattu aujourd'hui
parler à députés avant d'arriver au
sénat demain mais la contestation reste
vive dans la rue deux cents manifestants
se sont introduits dans l'hôtel de ville
de chambéry et ont décroché le portrait
d' emmanuel macron objectifs ont testé
le pass alité à la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants un
rassemblement à paris également le
cortège est parti de convention et s'est
dirigé dans l'assemblée nationale on
retrouve tout de suite notre reporter 4
sa technique
katia bonsoir vous suivez ce
rassemblement le pass and iter est loin
de faire l'unanimité
[Musique]
oui en effet ici sur cette place proche
de l'assemblée nationale un cortège de
gilet jaune est venu rejoindre le
rassemblement initial
ils viennent ici exprimer leurs
positions ce projet de loi sanitaire se
plaignant d'une restriction des libertés
je vous propose d'écouter une
manifestante que les gens comprennent
bien je ne suis pas anti vax d'accord je
suis pour la liberté de choix chacun a
droit à voir sa liberté de se prendre
une injection ou pas c'est pour ça que
je suis aujourd'hui parce que le bât
sanitaire c'est ça le pass annie terre
si vous ne l'avez pas ça veut dire vous
n'êtes pas vacciné
vous avez le droit à rien donc
automatiquement ça devient une
obligation vaccinale mais détourné comme
d'habitude alors l'ambiance était
festive jusqu'à l'arrivée des députés un
souvenir et coquerel françois ruffin ugo
bernalicis et alexis corps bien certains
manifestants leur ont réservé un bon
accueil discutant avec eux leur posant
des questions d'autres les ont hués et
traité de collabo l'ambiance est un peu
électriques
ici se rappelle tout de même que au
parlement ce moment même et bien
à l'assemblée les députés insoumis se
battent contre ce projet de loi et ont
déposé de nombreux amendements est
d'ailleurs en ce moment même ils sont en
train de voter je vous propose d'écouter
alexis corbière de passage de la
manifestation
il ya une bagarre actuellement qui a
lieu dans l'hémicycle
elle vient de commencer c'est assez
serré il ya eu des votes 133%
gouvernement 130 compte voyez c'est à
trois voix près on va y retourner parce
que ça se joue à quelques mois mais on
voulait aussi apporté un salut amical je
pense à jérôme rodriguez soudan au dot
famille qui québec ce combat qui est
juste voilà et pour le faire voyez il ya
parfois des excès mais globalement le
mouvement aujourd'hui que c'est qu'ils
s'expriment c'est un moment qui n'est
pas nécessairement des faveurs à des
mesures contre contre évidemment locaux
vides mais qui n'est pas favorable à ce
passe obligatoire qui peut même
entraîner des licenciements
donc la bataille parlementaire est en
cours et avant de connaître l'issue des
votes je vous fais part de l'avis de la
cnil la commune commission informatique
et libertés elle appelle à bien
circonscrire l'extension du passé ni
terre car il ya atteint de fortes aux
libertés dans le projet proposé
estime-t-elle merci beaucoup katia à
pique nique aux environs donc de
l'assemblée nationale vous continuez à
suivre ce rassemblement on continue de
parler à dieu pas sanitaire avec et rémy
rebeyrotte député de la république en
marche de saône-et-loire et michel
larive député de la france insoumise de
la 2e circonscription de l'ariège
bonsoir à vous donc merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france ce soir je me tourne
d'abord vers vous rémy rebeyrotte le
projet de loi sur le pass and i ter la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
débattue en ce moment même à l'assemblée
nationale les débats plutôt houleux
comme on pouvait s y attendre ce projet
louette est il réellement la seule
solution pour lutter contre cette
quatrième vague
oui je crois qu'effectivement d'autres
solutions sofa confiné très rapidement
et intégralement les dix qui évidemment
n'est pas un choix non je voulais dire
mon dieu il ya trois mois j'étais très
défavorable à la généralisation du
personnel pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est qu'il n'y avait pas
d'alternative pour nos concitoyens qui
ne pouvaient pas à l'époque se faire
vacciner de manière massive
on était dans le début de la vaccination
les rendez-vous et est souvent compliqué
pour être tri et donc on était dans une
situation très différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons le variant delta
avec les problèmes imminents extrêmement
parce qu'il pose
mais nous avons heureusement le vaccin
la capacité vaccinale et la capacité
matelot de vacciner vite puisqu'elle
nous avions même les centres de
vaccination qui était en chute de
fréquentation
quand les choses ont semblé pour le
français allait mieux
en réalité nous avons pour d'une variant
et il faut rendre massivement la voie de
la vaccination
mais cette voie aujourd'hui elle est
ouvert très très clairement
alors le pass sanitaire ne pas se
traduire par la vaccination obligatoire
parce qu'il ya toujours sibilité des
tests pcr mais enfin quand même l'idéal
soyons clairs c'est la vaccination et
c'est d'aller le plus rapidement
possible accomplir ce ce droit est
finalement aussi ceux de voir ceux de
voix pour les ou michel larive vous
interpelle sur sur sa la france
insoumise a été l'un des premiers partis
à vouloir saisir le conseil
constitutionnel pour dénoncer cette loi
finalement le premier ministre a annoncé
qu' le saisir à lui même après
l'adoption du parlement qu'est ce que ça
vous évoque une une prise de conscience
finalement concernant une atteinte aux
libertés individuelles selon vous
et oui oui monsieur vous venez de le
dire même la cnil l'a dit et le premier
ministre à juste raison a dit qu'il
saisirait le conseil que je trie
constitutionnel et vous avez raison avec
le groupe ps gdr
la france a soumises va saisir le
conseil constitutionnel parce qu'elle
fectivement il y à de grave atteinte à
nos libertés individuelles dans ce texte
de loi
comprenez bien contre comprenez bien que
nous ne sommes pas contre la vaccination
je suis moi même vacciné et que
quasiment tout l'ensemble du groupe
parlementaire la france assouplisse
vaccinés ou en cours de vaccination non
ce qui se passe ici c'est que vous avez
par exemple de déclarations très fortes
de stigmatisation qui sont celles de
notre président de la république qui dit
pars toujours ont la même démarche
reconnaître le civisme et faire porter
la restriction sur les non vaccinés
plutôt que sur tous ça c'est
discriminatoire est derrière nous avons
elisabeth bornes qui nous dit on a
introduit une procédure de suspension du
contrat de travail sans rémunération
pour les salariés sont pas sanitaire
valide
là nous avons une rupture de notre
contrat social républicain
alors c'est à ce titre là que nous
imposons opa sanitaires mon collègue
très justement à rappeler qu'il y à
trois mois la république en marche et le
président en premier était défavorable à
l'install l'instauration d'un pass
sanitaire parce que lui-même trouvé que
c'était une atteinte aux libertés
individuelles
alors voilà voilà pourquoi nous nous
opposons à ce texte comment comment le
gouvernement compte il faire et surtout
quelles implications ceci va avoir
j'arrive d'avignon avignon il ya des
théâtres qui vont fermer là alors que je
leur ai dit la loi n'est pas passée
attendait qu'elle passe parce qu'elle
peut ne pas passer cette loi est donc là
ils nous disent nous n'aurons pas le
personnel
le syndeac notamment ne nous dit un
syndicat culturel qui nous dit nous
n'aurons pas le personnel pour pouvoir
faire les vérifications qui va faire les
vérifications de vérification en ariège
et une restauratrice qui me dit mais
comment je vais faire moi je vais
imposer la vaccination à mes salariés et
comment je vais faire quand les gens
vont s'asseoir je verrai l'ordre
décision impasse et leurs pièces
d'identité c'est pas mon boulot je suis
restauratrice
je suis pas policier j'ai rencontré des
gendarmes qui étaient tout aussi
dubitatif
il m'a dit écoute et on a vu que pour
nos amis pompiers
c'est est obligatoire et pas pour nous
on comprends pas parce qu'on côtoie
autant de public que nos amis pompiers
et donc voilà donc c'est une loi qui a
été décidée unilatéralement par le
président de la république qui n'est pas
préparée et qui à chaque fois va avoir
un impact sur les gens sur leur travail
considérable parce que ne vous inquiétez
pas il n'y aura pas sanitaires pour
rentrer dans le métro pour aller
travailler pour faire tourner la machine
économique pour que les les premiers de
cordée sont au boulot là il n'y a pas de
place solitaire c'est là près et donc là
nous avons nous un énorme problème et
monsieur cédric au ministre la dans
l'hémicycle vient de dire
qu'effectivement cette loi n'empêchera
peut-être pas der confinement ou
d'autres coups de feu à venir alors vous
voyez
par contre ce qui se passe c'est que ça
crée un précédent sacré de césure
démocratique et qui à mon humble avis
n'est pas dans le dans le principe de ce
mois je pense de notre république est
une république sociale et donner la
parole 1 concernant justement ce projet
de loi vous qu'on vous comprenez ces
inquiétudes des français vous comprenez
qu'ils ne puissent pas avoir de schéma
vaccinal complet avant avant la rentrée
et que c'est et que finalement comme
comme le dit michel larive 7 ce projet
de loi était un peu dans l'urgence et ça
met un peu la pression au français
surtout qu'une grande majorité des
français sont favorables à la
vaccination et que monsieur arrive pas
contre la vaccination oui choix du rhône
elles sont pour la vaccination
une grande d'accéder une grande majorité
de français vaccinés souhaitent ou
maximum éviter de nouveaux des
reconfigurations une économie allant de
vos jeux dédire dysfonctionnements au
sein de notre économie plus aussi
vous avez une vie que je qualifierais de
agréable et normal et donc une grande
majorité françaises soyons clairs sont
aujourd'hui tout à fait favorables au
projet de loi est tout à fait favorable
à la vaccination
il reste certain nombre de français et
c'est tout à fait légitime tout le monde
s'exprime on peut aller effectivement on
peut venir manifester à proximité de
l'assemblée nationale avec le soutien de
la france a soumise tout ça est
parfaitement j'allais dire organiser et
c'est tout à fait légal de notre paix ni
d aucun problème mais il faudrait pas
prendre
j'allais dire comment dire il faudrait
pas prendre les dessine des oppositions
et des minorités pour le désir de la
match nul ça vous vous laissez pas la
république c'est pas la république c'est
peut-être monsieur darribes mais c'est
pas la note rémi à signaler c'est que la
plupart des manifestants que l'on peut
voir dans la rue ne sont pas contre la
vaccination n'est contre le pass
sanitaires les usages quotidiens et
c'est cette mesure qui est importante
merci merci merci monsieur alors écoutez
de chers collègues vous venez de dire
que les français étaient en majorité
pour le vaccin
nous ne sommes pas contre le vaccin nous
sommes contre la manière autoritaire de
procédés de le gouvernement procède et
en plus je vous le redis ou peut-être
même pas entendu le cédric aulas dit ça
n'hésitera pas à re confinement si
jamais il fallait faire donc ne dit pas
que ça évite un confinement
ensuite s'il vous plaît soyez courtois
j'étais courteau nous ne sommes pas à
l'origine des manifestations
nous descendons à la rencontre des
citoyens et je mange je pense que vous
devriez le faire un peu plus souvent et
vous entendrez effectivement ce qu'ils
disent ensuite je vais vous dire que
vous dit quelque chose de trop la
majorité des français et contre cette
loi
vous ne pouvez pas dire ce qu'ils vont
bon vous semble et sachez quand même
qu'en démocratie monsieur en démocratie
l'opposition à la parole alors si vous
n'aimez pas la démocratie et c'est ce
que l'on boit et bien tant pis pour vous
nous on continuera à être démocrate et
les français aussi
alors vous savez quoi soit vous changer
nos façons de faire on va laisser à
répondre rémy
rebeyrotte pardon face à sète cette
intervention michel arrive on vous
écoute oui non je dis simplement que les
principes de la république d'être la
démocratie c'est que effectivement la
majorité respecte les oppositions et les
oppositions respecte de la majorité
c'est que ça marche dans les deux sens
moi je voulais simplement dire à
monsieur larry qu'il regarde
effectivement aujourd'hui les enquêtes
d'opinion une grande majorité des
français pour la vaccination
une grande majorité des français
considère qu'il ne faut absolument pas
se résigner à l'idée de re confiner le
pgi active fois les massivement vers la
vaccination
je vais vous dire une chose sur la rive
moi j'étais très inquiet j'étais très
inquiet parce qu'il ya un champ les
maires de la circonscription le disais
il ya plus personne dans nos
vaccinodromes la fréquentation est en
chute massive
les gens considèrent qu' on a tourné la
hache que c'est terminé et cetera et en
plus il me disait on est en train de
sacrifier les salles pour des vaccinaux
groupe qui ne vaccinent plus or ces
salles en un appoint pour les
associations dans la démocratie locale
pour nos actions j'ai dû dire au
bénéfice de la population
pas moi où je suis ravie si vous l'échec
depuis l'intervention du président de la
république
ces centres fonctionnent les françaises
font vacciner
et moi je suis est ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise excusez moi même je
suis ravi que nous retrouvions le schéma
de la vaccination et qu'il y ait cette
volonté de la part de nos concitoyens de
se faire vacciner d'encourager la
vaccination de faire de la pédagogie
tous ensemble autour de la vaccination
pour relever ce défi qui est devant nous
et et comme dans tous les pays tous les
pays
le défi c'est la vaccination pour
essayer de faire face pour l'instant
nous avons la chance
les variants sont tous résilient au
vaccin
j'espère que ça va durer comme ça et que
nous pourrons petit à petit sortir dans
une d'une situation qui est n'est ni
favorable aux entreprises et aux
salariés ni à qui que ce soit dans notre
pays on va conclure rapidement avec vous
michel larive juste cette question
concernant cette contestation populaire
on a vu que de nombreux français étaient
contre ceux là pas sanitaires à usage
quotidien
certains vont vont trop loin par exemple
en faisant cette cette comparaison a à
l'étoile jaune vous pensez pas que c'est
exagéré selon vous mais bien entendu les
ont la vie ne participons pas à ça par
contre je reviens sur ce qui a été dit
la majorité de frêles des français sont
peut-être pour le vaccin mais contre
cette loi c'est deux choses différentes
et je vous le redis
si vous vous êtes très inquiet pour ce
qu'il se passe et la recrudescence des
juristes dans notre pays nous assistons
en responsabilité nous aussi mais je
vais vous dire que par exemple je suis
aussi très inquiet j'arrive d'avignon et
je suis très inquiet qu'il ait plus
personne par exemple dans les théâtres
en ce moment il ya des théâtres qui
décide de fermer parce qu'ils se disent
à quelque chose s'ils vont être mangés
idem pour des restaurants quand des
gendarmes retient une dame qui veut se
jeter dans dans un fleuve parce qu'elle
dit ne pourra pas avoir de travail
comprenez il est instauré dans notre
pays un climat de tension extrême
monsieur je vous le demande en
responsabilité retirer cette loi
refaites autre chose nous vous
accompagnerons dans une autre chose dans
la pédagogie comme sont les allemands
les allemands ne veulent pas faire comme
nous madame merkel a raison
pédagogie et gestes barrières vous avez
deux mois pour mettre des purificateurs
dans des écoles
lucho s'était de roulement en
responsabilité nous pourrions de vous
accompagner dans ce sens là mais nous
sommes contre les lois liberticides
parce que nous sommes peut-être les
derniers garants des valeurs
républicaines
souvent seule mais nous continuerons
nous lutterons contre le l'autoritarisme
et la cause l'obscurantisme qui
l'accompagnent sachez le nous serons
toujours là pour mettre en valeur nos
valeurs républicaines et surtout les
protéger merci à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir d'avoir
débattu autour de ce passage était à
rémy bohren je rappelle que le député de
la république en marque de
saône-et-loire et michel larive député
de la france insoumise de la 2e
circonscription de l'ariège
direction la tunisie où la situation
épidémique est catastrophique le
ministre de la santé était limogée la
campagne de vaccination est chaotique
le tout alors que le pays célèbre l'aïd
el kébir une des plus importantes fêtes
musulmanes mais cette année les
tunisiens n'ont pas le coeur à la fête
ce alors que beaucoup des proches en
réanimation d'autres faute de moyens ont
dû faire l'impasse sur la célébration de
cette fête les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis assem xavi la fête
du sacrifice sur la cérémonie la plus
importante du calendrier musulman à
cette année un goût amer en cause une
crise économique sans précédent et une
situation sanitaire des plus
inquiétantes face au manque de moyens
beaucoup de tunisiens ont dû faire
l'impasse sur cette célébration écoutez
je n'ai pas fêté l'aïd cette année ni
moi ni mes frères car nous n'avons pas
les moyens
notre peuple est pauvre et on est devenu
encore plus pauvres depuis ce qu'ils
appellent la révolution j'ai une
maîtrise en droit privé et je n'ai rien
célébré cette année
comment voulez vous que je pense à
acheter un mouton alors qu'il n'est même
pas les moyens d'acheter un poulet cette
année je n'ai pas fêté l'aïd et je ne
suis pas la seule dans ce cas
ma famille mes amis et même les voisins
tout simplement car la vie est devenue
trop chère dites-moi qui peut se payer
un mouton à 700 800 voire mille dinars
alors que je ne gagne que 300 dinars par
mois
si j'enlève mes factures d'électricité
d'eau et les frais d'éducation de ma
fille il ne me reste rien je suis veuve
comment voulez vous que je m'en sorte
comment voulez vous que j'aille au
marché pour acheter des courses des
fêtes
il n'y aucune organisation cette année
pour les fêtes au niveau du gouvernement
les différents ministères ne sont même
pas capables de se mettre d'accord sur
un protocole sanitaire pour permettre la
célébration de l'aïd
les tunisiens ont leurs habitudes leurs
traditions mais cette année avec la
crise du coc vide
rien ne peut se passer comme d'habitude
le monde entier souffre du coc vide mais
en tunisie c'est pire qu'ailleurs car
les caisses de l'état sont à sec crise
politique économique encore sanitaires
ont balayé l'effervescence habituelle
qui règne en cette période de fêtes
alors que le gouvernement a promis une
sortie de crise politique et une
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination pour freiner la
recrudescence des cas de contamination
au kovy 19 alors que la communauté
internationale s'est montrée solidaire
le pays dispose désormais d'environ 3
millions
deux doses et devrait passer à 5
millions de vaccins disponibles vers la
mi-août peut être un bon début pour que
la tunisie sortent enfin de son
cauchemar
on en vient ce scandale d'espionnage
retentissant la sphère et gaz us
emmanuel macron seraient visés par le
maroc et a lancé une série
d'investigations à en croire un les mots
du premier ministre
après les révélations d'espionnage de
milliers de numéros dans le monde une
enquête a été ouverte à paris
les précisions milla loiseau le
président de la république et plusieurs
de ses collaborateurs ont ils été placé
sur écoutes
le logiciel espion pegasus aurait ciblé
l'un des téléphones des manuels
maquereau en 2019 mais aussi ceux de 14
membres du gouvernement de l'époque
parmi eux edouard philippe christophe
castaner nicole belloubet ou encore jean
yves le drian
ce logiciel officiellement outils de
lutte contre le terrorisme aurait été
utilisé à d'autres fins par le maroc
une action qui ne doit pas rester impuni
pour certains ça prouve au moins que le
maroc qui clame un de trop notre
meilleur allié est un allié que l'on
doit regarder avec beaucoup de prudence
et probablement même que l'on devrait
traiter un peu différemment ce que je
rappelle que jusqu'à présent la france a
toujours largement protégé dès qu'il y
avait des exactions les autorités
marocaines
j'espère en tout cas aujourd'hui que
devant ces violations extrêmement grave
et cette démonstration qu'en fait le
maroc se comporte comme le pire de nos
ennemis cette fois-ci enfin la france va
réagir et et mettra un terme à
l'impunité marocaine en france logiciels
créés par l'entreprise israélienne nso
pegasus une fois introduit dans les
smartphones est capable de récolter des
données privées comme les messages ou
les photos pire encore il peut prendre
le contrôle du micro et de la caméra de
la personne visée depuis 2000 16 50
mille numéros ont été ciblés dont plus
de 1000 en france selon le consortium de
médias qui a révélé la sphère des
parlementaires des avocats et des
journalistes ont été espionnés par le
maroc
la classe politique française
inquiète c'est l'intrusion dans nos
téléphones portables par par une
dispositif qui est un dispositif on ne
sait pas par qui les contrôle et comment
à quoi ça sert c'est terrible c'est
terrible parce que dans nos téléphones
aujourd'hui on a nos vies quand même
c'est aussi le signe de la faiblesse de
nos outils de sécurité de protection des
plus hauts dirigeants français donc il
faudra en tirer toutes les conséquences
des conséquences diplomatiques
économiques peut-être parce que il faut
réagir à cette agression mais aussi il
faut en tirer toutes les conséquences
sur les failles béantes dans nos outils
de protection de son côté le maroc a
catégoriquement démenti le recours aux
logiciels pegasus par ses services de
sécurité pour espionner des
personnalités françaises
une enquête a été ouverte mardi par le
parquet de paris
pour claude blanchou maison expert en
relations internationales ces
révélations on n'aura pas de n'auront
pas de réel impact sur les relations
entre le maroc et la france
cette situation est très sérieuse il y
aura évidemment des protestations
français est réveillé vigoureuse mais il
est probable que ça n'ira pas au delà
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
après wikileaks lorsqu'on a appris que
la nsa américaine et coûté à peu près
tout le monde
il ya eu des protestations c'est
scandaleux c'est inadmissible c'est
immoral mais on s'en est tenu là et
entre la france et le maroc les intérêts
contre les intérêts mutuels sont très
importants d'abord parce qu'il ya une
communauté marocaine en france une
communauté française au maroc
ensuite parce que les liens économiques
sont retrad is you nellement très fort
et je pense que le refroidissement ne
durera que quelques temps
une année depuis en trois jours voilà ce
qu'a subi la chine centrale des pluies
diluviennes ont provoqué de fortes
inondations dans la ville de zhangzhou à
700 km de pékin le bilan s'élève pour
l'heure à au moins 25 morts et plus de
200 mille personnes ont été évacuées au
nord de la ville un autre barrage menace
de s'effondrer
l'armée a été déployée sur place sont
fait le point avec marion konan pris au
piège dans le métro certains passagers
se cramponne tant bien que mal au
poignet
les habitants de zinc nous attendent les
secours qui peine à les atteindre
d'autres ont réussi à sortir et reste
sous le choc
l'impact de l'eau de la crue était si
puissant que j'ai dû enlever ma chemise
mon sac à dos est tout sauf mon pantalon
tout le monde s'accrocher aux rails le
long du tunnel
il y en avait en tout plus d'une
douzaine de personnes on s'est serré les
coudes en avançant lentement l'eau
arrivait jusqu'aux épaules
l'autoroute était si fort que certains
pays ont été emportées
nous avons brisé la partie supérieure de
la vitre pour laisser entrer un peu
d'air sinon on suffoquait en trois jours
l'équivalent d'une année de pluie est
tombée sur la métropole placée en alerte
rouge ce sont les précipitations les
plus fortes depuis 60 ans face à ces
scènes de chaos
le président chinois évoque une
situation extrêmement grave avec
notamment des barrages effondré une
chaîne de solidarité s'est mise en place
pour secourir un maximum d'habitants des
pompiers de province voisine et l'armée
ont été appelés en renfort
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes assez bien avec nous sur rtl
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse
d'industriels et extrêmement contrôlée
pourquoi puisque on reverse 50 5 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à
la commune ils sont donc très intéressé
au fait que le
fonctionnement soit line ont fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurance parce qu il ya
d'argent suspects nous sommes dans
l'obligation de déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85%
nous on n'a absolument aucun intérêt à
ce que quelqu'un